i've always thought of bitcoin as a very
binary investment whether it goes from
80 to 8 000 to 6000 to 3000 to 13 000 it
just it doesn't matter
this is either
zero
or it's millions
because what it will do is it will
create a quasi gold standard
it'll create an index
except instead of having to own gold
where gold is owned by central banks
it is an instrument that has
value that's determined by and between
its participants
and it's owned by everybody
so
maybe the correct way to say this is
that it's not
gold but in gold being gold 2.0 which
some people have used about bitcoin
what it does is it replaces the
the method of value transfer that you
need for fiat money to be valuable but
that only happens if the us dollar looks
like it's going to careen into this wall
so i think that's the best so the setup
is here so before
there was no path dependence meaning you
were speculating and not really hoping
because you know if you were if you're
using it schmuck insurance as i was you
were kind of hoping it would never come
in
but now if the probability you know was
one percent that that it would be
valuable
unfortunately the probability is now
probably like five or ten percent
um
and there is a real chance by 2030
um
we don't find a way to inflate our way
out of this and that the only way to
break the back of deflation is
essentially to create some quasi form of
gold standard but it'll be almost
impossible to do that between
governments and central banks they'll
never agree on an instrument and they'll
never agree on an exchange but then
bottoms up people could decide to do it
yeah and the minute that that happens
individuals and people then it's a done
deal